MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
to "Talks at Google."
Please join me today in
welcoming Bay Area journalist
Marina Krakovsky, the author
of "The Middleman Economy."
Just published.
Marina's writing has appeared in
"The New York Times Magazine,"
"The Washington Post,"
the "Stanford Magazine,"
"Scientific American,"
"Discover," "Psychology Today,"
and "Slate."
Marina was also a researcher
for Eric Schmidt and Jonathan's
book, "How Google Works."
Marina has earned
a BA in English
from Stanford University.
Thank you for coming
to Google today.
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Thank you.
All right.
So I'm here to tell you
that we are all middlemen.
I'm a middleman.
You guys are middlemen.
And what I will say
is why I say that.
And also, I'll give you
ways to think about how you
could be a better middleman.
So if we think back to the day
when the internet was still
in its early years
and people were all
trying to figure out what's this
going to mean for all of us,
a lot of people were saying that
the internet's radical ability
to connect everybody would
make middlemen obsolete.
Bill Gates actually wrote in
his 1995 book, "The Road Ahead,"
that the internet itself would
become the ultimate go-between,
the universal middle man.
He foresaw a time in the
future when we wouldn't
need to turn to middlemen.
We would be able to do our own
buying and selling directly.
But if you look
around 20 years later,
you see, very clearly, that
that actually has not happened.
In fact, I'll argue that
the opposite has happened.
That the internet has made
middlemen more prevalent
and more valuable.
So look at the biggest
players on the internet.
eBay and Amazon are
middleman businesses.
Uber and Airbnb are
Google is a middleman business.
Right?
And I'm not just talking
about tech giants.
I'm also talking about
individual middlemen
who are thriving thanks to
the tools of the internet.
So think about eBay.
Anybody can buy
and sell directly
through eBay being a middleman
but most of the trade on eBay
actually flows
through resellers,
through trusted
middlemen on eBay.
And on LinkedIn, something
very similar happens.
It's all about the recruiters.
Recruiters bring in more
of LinkedIn's revenue
then all the other
LinkedIn users combined.
So the internet clearly
didn't do away with middlemen.
It's actually made them
more efficient, and often,
more effective at what they do.
So I've been thinking
for a very long time
about what is the deal
with middlemen, basically.
I mean, it's so strange.
Middlemen have been a part of
every society that I know of.
Throughout history
we've had middlemen.
And yet, people have often had
very strong negative feelings
about middlemen,
feelings of resentment,
anger, contempt,
sometimes even disgust.
And, at the same time,
middlemen are still there.
Or to put it another
way, if people
are so eager to
eliminate the middlemen,
why have we never
been able to do so?
These are the driving
questions behind my book
and that those are the questions
that I really tried to answer.
So I talked to economists and
psychologists and sociologists
who think about such issues.
But also with
ordinary-- or you might
say extraordinary--
middlemen, people
who I think do a great job
and are doing just fine--
thank you very much-- in
the age of the internet.
So it's people that you might
expect, like real estate agents
and travel agents
and car dealers.
But also people that
it might take you
a moment to realize that
they are middlemen, too.
So, for example, gosh, a
wedding planner is a middleman.
If you pause to think
about that, right?
A venture capitalist
is a middleman.
A person who started a two-sided
market, like Open Table,
that's a middleman.
There are middlemen all over.
Gallerists are middlemen.
Anytime you're dealing with any
kind of broker, dealer, anybody
who's connecting two groups
of people, that's a middleman.
And what's interesting
from talking
to all these different people
is that even though they're
from different industries,
you start to see patterns.
You start to see what
they have in common
that is making them as effective
and successful as they are.
And that's sort of what I
started to do in my book,
is to tease out those
commonalities that
are true everywhere.
And although all the examples
that I use throughout the book
and throughout my
presentation will
be of professional
middlemen-- people who
identify as middlemen
in their jobs--
I do believe that all
of us are middlemen,
at least in some area of our
work or in our personal lives.
So what do I mean
by a middleman?
I think we all have an
intuition about this.
And we think of a middle
man is the person connecting
two groups of people or
two individuals, the person
in-between.
But I want to give you a more
useful definition that explains
what middlemen actually do.
And this definition
comes from a man
named Mike Maples, Jr. He's
a venture capitalist here
in the valley.
Started a fund called Floodgate
that was an early investor
in Lyft and TaskRabbit--
middleman businesses--
as well as, of course,
other start-ups.
And he says this.
A middleman is the
person in a network who
connects nodes in the
network to increase
the value of the network.
I think it's a
useful definition,
and I'm going to talk a lot
more about what that means.
But I also want to
acknowledge that middleman
is a sexist word.
I realize it's a sexist word.
And I'm using it despite
that because I really
think no other word will
capture what I'm trying to do,
which is really push
against these cultural ideas
about middlemen.
You know, that word has
these strong connotations.
We just don't hear
people saying,
ah, let's cut out
the intermediary.
It's really about the middleman.
So forgive me for
using that word.
There's a reason.
So going back to this
idea that middlemen
are people who we increase
the value of a network
by connecting nodes.
I do think it's a
really helpful start,
but it's not a
complete definition.
And the reason it's not complete
is that not all connectors
are of equal quality.
Right.
We know that.
And if you think
about Metcalfe's law--
I would guess everybody in
this room knows what that is.
Metcalfe's law, this
provocative claim
that the value of a
network grows quadratically
with the number of
connected users.
Well, that may not be true.
It may be true sometimes.
It's certainly not true
for every additional user
you add to a network.
And if you think about it
in terms of middlemen--
or if you think of it in
terms of any kind of user,
actually-- if you have a
network that has a certain value
and you take out
some of those nodes,
sometimes taking
out a single node
will just decimate the network.
It'll radically decrease
the value of the network.
And sometimes taking
out a node will
have almost no effect at all.
And sometimes taking
out a node will actually
increase the value
of the network
because some of these
connectors are actually
having a net negative effect
on the value of a network.
So if you think
about spammers, that
would be an example of
something like that.
So it is really
important to think
about connectors' quality.
But how do you think
about connectors' quality?
What is it that defines
the quality of a connector
or of a middleman?
And the way I find it
useful to think about it
is in terms of these
two dimensions.
One is warmth, and the
other is competence.
Warmth and competence.
And these are specialized
terms that social psychologists
use when they're talking about
how we judge other people.
So this isn't just
true about middlemen.
This is true about human
judgment in general.
When we meet
somebody, we quickly
evaluate them based
on our perceptions
of the person's warmth, which
is all about their intentions.
Are they friend or foe?
Are they on my side or not?
And competence, which
is a separate issue.
And that's really
all about the ability
to deliver on those intentions.
Those are totally separate.
And if you combine
them, you quickly
generate this nice
two-by-two matrix
with four possible combinations.
And I want to talk
through each of these
so you know what
I'm talking about.
I think that these
labels that I've come up
with really capture
some of the emotion
and some of the
ambivalence that we
have about middlemen because
middlemen are not all created
equal.
They really vary in quality
across these two dimensions.
So clearly, the
worst type is the one
I call the parasite
person, who is
low in warmth and competence.
After the financial crisis
of 2008, a lot of people
put the bankers on Wall
Street in that quadrant.
They've actually
done studies on this,
and companies like
Goldman Sachs and AIG
landed squarely in that
cold, incompetent quadrant.
We don't need to
say much about that.
What's more interesting
is these ambivalent cases.
So, the predator-- the person
who is competent, but really
doesn't have your
interests at heart--
this is the person
that we tend to resent.
And I don't know about
you guys, but this is how
I feel about my cable company.
They're competent.
They're able to deliver high
speed internet and video
to my home.
But clearly, they don't have
my best interests at heart.
They seem to be taking advantage
of their monopolistic power
for their personal
gain, not for us.
They have high prices,
terrible customer service.
All of that makes me think that
they're not warm at all, even
if they're competent.
Now the pet is maybe a little
bit better because they're
at least on your side.
But unfortunately,
they can't really
deliver on those
good intentions.
And, to my mind, a
good example would
be the stereotypical
mom-and-pop shop.
So the service might
be really slow.
You might have to place a
special order and wait for it
to be delivered.
The prices are high.
But it's not because
they're trying to gouge you.
They're not trying to
take advantage of you.
They really mean well.
They just can't do any
better, unfortunately.
And this sort of person
evokes feelings of pity.
So you might patronize
a store like that
because you feel bad for them.
But if the difference
in price, or quality,
speed, and all those
sorts of things--
if that difference grows
to a certain point,
you're going to give up on them.
You're still going to go with
the retail giant instead.
So clearly, the best type
of middleman to deal with
is the partner.
Both warm and competent,
they have your best interests
at heart.
And they're really
able to deliver
on those good intentions.
So I think everybody wants
to deal with a partner.
And everybody should
want to be a partner.
And way to think
about being a partner
is going back to this
idea of increasing
the value of a network
by connecting nodes.
What partners are
able to do is they're
able to increase
the size of the pie.
And then take as their
slice-- you know,
their markup, their
commission, their fee.
And after they take that slice
for creating that extra value,
you still feel like you are
way better off than if you
hadn't partner with them.
And so being a partner puts
you in a very strong position
because people really want
to do business with you.
They're not just doing
business with you
because they feel sorry for
you or because they currently
don't have any alternatives,
but because you really
are providing a
great value to them.
So this is my foundation
for everything
I'm going to say today.
We've got this idea of a good
middleman, the admirable kind
of middleman as a partner.
They create value.
You appreciate them.
And then the question
becomes, well,
how exactly do
they create value?
This is a very fuzzy
notion of creating value
by connecting
nodes in a network.
What is it that
they're doing exactly?
And this is really what
most of my book is about.
I distill it into six problems
that middlemen solve--
that good middlemen solve.
And I think that you will all
find yourself in a middleman
position at some point.
And I hope that as I
continue discussing
what these middlemen
do, you'll see, yeah,
sometimes I do that in my work.
Or I see somebody
else doing that.
And maybe I should be
doing more of this.
I hadn't thought of that.
And that's the idea anyway.
So what do middlemen
do to create value,
to be a valued partner?
Well, the very first
problem that they solve
is what I call the
problem of distance.
Distance can take
many forms-- well,
three forms that I
talk about anyway.
There's physical, you
know, geographic distance.
That's pretty obvious.
But you can also have temporal
distance and social distance.
So with physical
distance, it's two people
who would both benefit from
doing business together--
some kind of trade-- but
they're just too far apart.
And the merchant steps in
and connects them that way,
indirectly.
With temporal distance,
we don't usually
think of middlemen this way.
But that's actually
what a lot of them do.
So my favorite example of
this is an appliance flipper
on Craigslist.
I'm sure you guys have
all used Craigslist.
What this guy does is he's like
a super user of Craigslist,
a power user of Craigslist.
He's just constantly
on the site.
He knows all about the prices
for the kinds of products
that he buys and sells
because he has to.
He lives off of that difference,
that markup between what he
buys for and what he sells for.
So he'll buy a used
washer or dryer for $50.
That's the price
he's aiming for.
He'll do that on Saturday,
take the appliance off
of somebody's hands.
He'll quickly turn around
and post that same listing
on Craigslist and then sit and
wait and does his other work,
and sits and waits
until somebody
can match his
asking price, which
is typically $250 or $300.
And then when that
person comes back--
it might be a couple
days later-- he
sells it to them for
that higher price.
So they're a bridge in time.
They're a bridge between
the seller on a Saturday
and the buyer on a
Monday or Tuesday.
Social distance, this
is another problem.
And this is really the
biggest problem of all.
And it presents the
most opportunity.
Because, what you
often have-- this
is a very typical pattern
for social networks--
is that people tend to be
with other people like them.
Birds of a feather flock
together is the saying.
And so if you map
the social structure,
what you end up having
is a cluster of people
who all know each other here.
And then another cluster here
and another cluster there.
But then you have these
gaps between the clusters.
The structural holes is
what sociologists call them.
And what structural holes
do is they create problems
with transferring
information, but they also
create opportunities
for middlemen
who can act as bridges.
They're bridging these
gaps in the social fabric.
So, an example,
there's an entrepreneur
I spoke with who, when
she was a college student,
saw an expectant mother,
a heavily pregnant woman,
putting up fliers in
this young woman's dorm.
She was looking for a nanny.
And she thought, there are
so many college students,
I'm bound to be able
to find a nanny here.
Now, this is in the Boston
area, and there are just so
many college students
in the Boston area.
It would be very inefficient
to go and do this.
And it's just silly
for an expectant mother
to be doing this or for
anybody to be doing this.
And so you've got
for these people.
There's a cluster of college
students, many clusters
of college students.
And then you have many
clusters of families.
And the families may
talk to each other.
And the college students
may talk to each other.
But they're separated
across social distance.
And so what the
entrepreneur did is
she saw this
bridging opportunity.
This was in the early
days of e-commerce.
And she started a
service called Sittercity
that connects these two groups.
And now, we have many,
many such services.
And that doesn't
seem so remarkable.
But I'm just showing
you this as an example
of how, even within the
same geographic area,
you might have the
need for a bridge.
All right.
So this bridge in
social structure
is pretty foundational
to solving
a lot of the other problems
that I'm going to describe.
So let's take the
problem of quality.
This is another problem
that middlemen solve.
Whenever you're
buying something,
you're kind of at the
mercy of the seller
because the seller
typically knows more
about what they're selling
then you, as the buyer, do.
All right.
So classic example
is a used car.
If you're selling
a used car, you
know how well you've taken
care of the car, what
problems it has, and so on.
And the buyer doesn't know that.
And this creates a real problem
for both sides, actually.
This is what the whole
market for lemons is about.
It's not just that the seller
is suspicious of the buyer
and is at a disadvantage.
The buyer ends up
being at a disadvantage
just against other
buyers because-- I
mean, sorry-- the seller.
How can the seller
prove that the car is in
as good a condition as
the seller knows it to be?
How can they justify that price?
So this is where a middleman
can help because a middleman is
doing trade constantly.
If you're selling a car, you're
doing it once every few years.
But someone who
specializes in selling cars
is doing it all the time.
So a really clear
demonstration of how
a middleman can solve
this quality problem
is apparent on eBay.
Because on eBay,
it's all right there.
You can see who is
doing the selling.
You can see a record of
their transactions over time.
What everybody wants is a
high feedback score on eBay
because it makes buyers
trust that person more.
The problem is, it's
very hard to build up
that kind of positive score,
that positive reputation
on eBay, if you're only
selling occasionally.
You see?
This is why being a middleman
gives you an advantage
because-- one of many
reasons-- is that you're
buying and selling a lot.
And so you can much
more quickly build up
a reputation as someone
who delivers on the quality
that they're promising.
So one of the people I
interviewed for the book
is a woman who is a
PowerSeller on eBay.
PowerSeller is
eBay's designation
for its most active
and reputable sellers.
She gave up a career
as an appellate lawyer
to sell luxury
designer goods on eBay
because, gosh, it
was just a quick way
to become an entrepreneur.
And she's an expert
on this stuff.
That's one of the keys.
You have to really be good
at sussing out quality.
And she's staking her
reputation on everything
that she sells on the site.
She really guards that
average feedback score on eBay
because she knows that all
her future sales depend on it.
So this is the advantage
that a middleman has.
They're an expert in quality.
And they're really able
to lay their reputation
on the line with every sale.
So I call this type of
middleman, the certifier.
And, by the way, we often talk
about people saying things
like, we don't need gatekeepers.
Gatekeepers are evil.
Let's bypass the gatekeepers.
Let's do our own thing.
Well, gatekeepers
are actually very
valuable for this very reason.
It's in their interest to close
the gates when crap is coming
through, and to
open them up when
they see something of quality.
And when we're buying,
as consumers of goods,
of cultural products,
it's valuable to use
the services of the gatekeeper
because we know that there's
a stamp of approval.
You're not going to
see a lot of schlock
go through a great gatekeeper.
All right.
So the third problem is the
problem of accountability.
Accountability is related
to the problem of quality,
except with quality, you're
just dealing with goods.
With accountability, you're
dealing with services.
So let's say you need
to hire somebody.
How do you know, regardless
of that person's track
record or underlying
quality, how
do you know that
they're going to deliver
for you, that they're going
to do a good job for you?
And again, you have
the same problem
that the infrequent seller
or the infrequent buyer
does in the certifier scenario.
If you're only
selling something,
a service, occasionally,
how can you
prove that you really are an
honest, accountable person who
works hard and so on?
And, as the buyer, how can
you ascertain that as well?
So again, middlemen
to the rescue.
I'll give you an example.
A modeling agent, an
agent who represents
models for
photographers or brands
that need to hire models.
This is a person who's
keeping both sides honest.
I'm using that as
an umbrella term,
keeping both sides
honest, to capture
that whole notion of
accountability that
can take many forms.
So in the case of a
model, being accountable
means that you're
going to show up.
That's the main thing.
You're going to show up on
time-- which, by the way,
in the modeling world means
15 minutes-- or at least
15 minutes-- before
the shoot starts.
And for the other
side, the photographer
or the brand who's
taking pictures,
that they stick to the
letter of the contract,
that they uphold
the contract terms.
So if they are allowed to
use these images in a catalog
because that's
what they paid for,
the agency, the middleman
in this transaction,
is going to make
sure that they don't
slap on those pictures
on a big billboard.
So the middleman is able to
keep both sides accountable.
A model might still
flake out, but she'll
be less likely to flake out
when she's being represented
by the agency.
And the reason is
that the agency's
in a position to have
her brought in again
and again and again.
So she's got a
longer future horizon
when working through the agency
than if she's doing business
directly with a photographer.
Then she can say, uh,
it's not worth it for me.
Something-- a
better gig came up.
I'll just cancel
on you or whatever.
So that's an example
of accountability.
And it happens everywhere.
So, OK.
We've talked about
these several problems.
I'll also present
the problem of risk.
And, of course,
all of these things
that I've been talking
about-- the problem of quality
and the problem of
accountability--
do have to do with risk.
And that is the risk
that what you're buying
isn't what you
thought you would get.
But, when I talk about the
middleman as a risk bearer,
I'm really talking about
a different kind of risk.
And that is the kind of risk
that neither side can predict.
A lot of services in
the on-demand economy
actually deal with
this kind of risk.
It's those unpredictable
fluctuations in demand.
When are you going to
need to call up a car?
When is a car going to
be in this neighborhood?
None of these services know
when each of these events
is going to happen,
but because they're
pooling all these
resources-- they're
kind of building
a portfolio, you
might say-- then
in the aggregate,
they do know that
at this time you're
going to have somebody
who's going to need
a car in this neighborhood.
And you're going to
have a driver that's
within a certain radius
of this neighborhood.
So that's risk pooling.
That's the risk-bearing role.
And often, it has to
work hand-and-hand
with these other types of
risk, the quality problem
and the accountability problem.
The clear demonstration
of this is
with a service called ZocDoc.
It's another one of these
two-sided marketplaces.
It's sort of the OpenTable
for doctor's appointments.
So if you need to see a
doctor on short notice,
you can go to this website
and find someone in your area,
in the specialty that
you're looking for.
And for the doctors--
who are the ones who
are paying for this
service because it's
free to the patients--
for the doctors,
this is a great service
just like OpenTable
is for restaurants
because they often
have last-minute cancellations.
And they'd rather fill
that appointment slot.
So for each doctor,
it's unpredictable
when that opening
is going to show up.
But for the site, for the
service as a whole, for ZocDoc,
it's quite
predictable that, yes,
we can really count
on there being
a certain number of openings.
And we can count on a certain
amount of demand from patients.
And you have to keep
those in balance.
But here's the interesting
part is that it really
has to work hand-in-hand with
the work of accountability
and the work of
sussing out quality.
Because you're going to
run into this problem.
Who do you think will be the
doctors with the most openings?
That's the kind of risk.
Doctors who are not
very good, who have not
been able to build up
a very good reputation
in their community.
So everybody's going to
have, you know, these flukes.
Like, you know, very honest
reasons for having an opening.
But doctors who have a
disproportionately high number
of openings, you have to
wonder about these doctors.
And ZocDoc, as a middleman,
has to protect themselves
from that kind of risk.
They have to weed
out the bad doctors.
But they have to embrace
the other kind of risk,
which is that nobody
knows when you're
going to have an opening.
So this is where these
reputation systems come in.
It's almost an industry standard
now that all of these sites
have a way for users to
evaluate the other side.
At least in this case,
patients evaluate doctors.
And when doctors know that
they're going to be evaluated,
they're going to be,
presumably, on better behavior.
So they're not going to,
maybe, keep you waiting as long
as they would if you
were not transacting
through the middleman.
At least, that's the theory.
And it's in ZocDoc's
interest to keep
that system working very well.
So that's the risk bearer role.
And again, it comes up
in lots of other places.
There's another problem.
And I would call
this the problem
of information overload.
I think Google certainly
understands this problem.
It's like the official, you
know, mission of the company
to organize all the
world's information.
A lot of people don't
appreciate this.
That the more
information you have,
that's not necessarily
a good thing by itself.
Because then you
have the problem
of sifting through
this information,
processing the information
to make a good decision.
And Herbert Simon
said, pretty famously--
you guys might have
heard this quote--
that a wealth of information
creates a poverty of attention.
And by attention,
he just meant time.
Information consumes time.
If you've ever had to
plan a complex trip,
you probably can relate to this.
Humans actually have
a much harder time
than computers in
processing information
because we get overwhelmed.
We get emotionally overwhelmed.
And so we just get
paralyzed with indecision.
And so this is another rationale
for a middleman to step in.
So I call this role
the concierge role.
Just like you could do your
own research on whatever city
you're going to through
your iPad or whatever,
or you can go to a
concierge who can just
cut through all of that
and tell you exactly
where to go to meet your needs.
So that is the concierge role.
And I think computers
are going to be
doing more and more of that,
but we're not there yet.
We still can really benefit
from a good concierge.
By the way, this is where I
think real estate agents can
really step up their game.
We no longer need
real estate agents
to just tell you
what the listings are
if we're buying a house.
But we need them to guide us
through this long, complex,
high stakes transaction.
And I think that they could
be doing a better job at that
if they thought of
their role that way.
All right.
Finally, the last problem
that I think middlemen solve
is a problem that I'll
just call self-advocacy,
the problem of self-advocacy.
Which is the problem of trying
to advocate on your own behalf.
So we, just as humans, we have a
hard time tooting our own horn.
Much easier if somebody
else does that for us,
if somebody else introduces
us, if somebody else
says how great we are.
And also the problem of
pushing for what we want.
We're afraid of
rocking the boat.
And one of the middlemen I
interviewed for this book
really saw this problem
in his industry.
And we already see this
in other industries
like in sports agents, right.
They advocate on
behalf of the athlete.
So not only does
the athlete not have
to become an expert
in negotiation,
but the athlete can just
pretend that they're
just interested in the game,
and let the business sign be
taken care of by the middleman.
The person that I talked
to does the same thing
for young doctors.
So he's a doctor himself,
a more seasoned doctor.
And he's seen both sides.
Middlemen often do have
to be able to appreciate
the needs of both sides.
And he realized
that young doctors
are at a disadvantage
in negotiating
for their first job out of
residency or medical school.
And the disadvantages-- well,
there are many disadvantages.
One is they just don't
even have the information.
They don't have
experience negotiating.
But they're also
hamstrung by the fact
that throughout medical school,
it has been pounded into them
that medicine is
a higher calling.
It's not about the money.
And you shouldn't show
an interest in money
when you're talking to
your future employer.
But hospitals and clinics
take advantage of that norm.
And so they're able to get
these young doctors to just sign
whatever the first offer is.
So this agent is able
to step in and he's
able to say things
like, well, I know
you really need an ER doctor.
And I know that the median pay
in Kansas City for an ER doctor
is X. And so, let's
just move toward X
with this person
who's a young hire.
We don't know anything
about his quality.
So let's just take the
median salary as our target.
There's just no way that the
doctor-- even if the doctor had
that information-- would
feel comfortable saying
these things on her own behalf.
So that's a value that this
role that I call the insulator
provides.
So what's interesting
about all of these is they
all show-- they're all
able to wield power
on behalf of their client,
on behalf of their trading
partner.
Going back to this idea of
being an admirable middleman,
a true partner.
But they're able to
do it without any kind
of a formal authority.
It's not like anybody's
reporting to this person.
But we're all gladly
partnering with these people.
We're all happily
using these services
because these
businesses are providing
true value to both sides.
And I want to just leave
you with this thought
about how this might
apply to you and how can
you start to see yourself
as a middleman as well.
So this diagram shows
somebody's actual map
of their LinkedIn connections.
LinkedIn no longer offers
this visualization service.
But if you were to manually
map all your connections,
I would bet that your diagram,
your own personal network
diagram, would look
much like this.
And this person, right
here in the middle,
is the user whose connections
are being mapped here.
And all these colors,
they refer to a cluster.
Remember, I was talking about
a typical social network having
clusters and having bridges,
and gaps between clusters
that can be bridged.
So, the blue cluster are all
employees of one company.
And maybe the orange
cluster is employees
of a previous employer that
this person has worked for.
And, I think, the green cluster
refers to some classmates
from college.
And the smallest cluster is
typically your family members.
Again, all these people know
each other, more or less,
because they're in the
same social circle.
That's what we would
say, social circle.
But they don't all know
each other across clusters.
And in this case, you sometimes
have people who overlap.
But the most prominent bridge
is the user, him or herself.
This is the person who
is a bridge across all
of these clusters.
So the idea here is that
we're all separated,
but we're all part of
a bunch of networks.
And if we can think
of ourselves as being
that middleman,
that middle person,
the person who can bridge all
of these different networks,
then we can increase the
value of our whole network.
And we can do it
through these ways
of being not just a bridge, but
also a certifier or an enforcer
of the accountability role.
Or, perhaps, an insulator
when you're saying something
on behalf of a co-worker
that they can't say
on behalf of themselves.
That's how you can be a more
valuable middleman yourself.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that historically we
have viewed middlemen as
something that we reviled.
However, clearly,
like you said, most
of the services
that we work with
are, essentially, middlemen.
Why do you think the
social perception
has changed for middlemen?
Why don't we revile, like,
Amazon or Google, as we would,
I don't know, an
older middleman?
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yeah.
Well, there are a lot of
answers to that question.
So first of all, middlemen
as a group are still reviled.
I follow this word
on Twitter because I
want to join conversations
about middlemen.
And people still say things
like, cut out the middleman.
This service cuts
out the middleman.
And they're not seeing that,
well, this service, actually,
is a middleman, too.
So, that's one thing.
I'd say, in general,
people still
don't have this, like,
negative view of middlemen.
A lot of people wouldn't
see Amazon as a middleman.
Another answer is
that Amazon I would
put in that golden quadrant
of being a partner, at least
from the consumer's side.
If you talk to small
manufacturers who
try to sell through Amazon, you
might hear a different answer.
So I think that the ones that
we look to as admirable ones,
we just don't call
them a middleman.
AUDIENCE: So middleman is
a more semantic thing then?
We just call things middlemen
that we don't like middlemen,
but the middlemen
that we like, we
don't realize that
they are middlemen?
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yeah.
I do think it's largely
a semantic issue.
Yes, that if we like
them, we call them
a retailer or my trusted agent.
We don't use the word middleman.
I think so.
AUDIENCE: Can talk a
little bit about the role
of universities as middlemen?
Because, to some extent, they're
certifiers and networks and--
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yeah.
Universities are, definitely,
middlemen for the reason
that you identified.
A lot of people
would say that that's
actually their main role,
is just to certify you.
You know, like, oh,
you got into MIT.
Well, that's good enough for me.
I don't even care
what you learn at MIT.
So that certifier role
is really important.
They actually work as
middlemen in other ways,
too, because there's a real--
at least, a two-sidedness.
You know, the idea
of a two-sided market
where the buyers want to
be where the sellers are.
The sellers want to be
where the buyers are.
There's a way in which
universities are like that.
So if you think about
a good university,
they attract good
students because they
have great faculty.
And then great faculty want
to work at a university that
has smart, motivated students.
And there are other
effects like that.
AUDIENCE: So, do you
see any problems?
I mean, all of this
sounds excellent.
But I'm thinking now of
the physician's metric
that you mentioned.
And do such middleman
services actually create
behaviors that otherwise
would not be created?
For example, some
people may think,
you know, oh, this
is a bad doctor.
He treated me in a certain way.
But the doctor is actually--
his cure is performing well,
but his personal skills
may not be up to par.
So--
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --he gets,
like, a bad review.
And now you have
this network effect
which may be multiplying this.
And suddenly strange
things happen.
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Definitely.
Yeah.
That is not a perfect
system with ZocDoc.
I mean, doctors really
think-- and a lot of people
would say this-- gosh, what
business do patients even
have evaluating doctors?
If you were as expert at
medicine as the doctor is,
why would you even
need a doctor?
And you could say that about
any of these middlemen services.
To a large extent, we turn to
middlemen because we cannot,
we just don't have that
expertise ourselves.
And so, I would say
that these services
do have-- these
rating systems do
skew the ratings in
a certain direction
that they measure certain
things more than others.
Clearly, things like the
doctor's bedside manner
and how long they
kept you waiting
weigh heavily,
much more heavily,
than other factors that somebody
else would find important.
Yeah.
It's not a perfect system.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just trying to think
about the role of technology
taking over middlemen roles.
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I just
wondering if you
have thoughts on are
there certain roles
or characteristics of
these roles of middlemen
that are inherently human?
That technology,
maybe, conceivably
could never take over?
MARINA KRAKOVSKY:
I really don't.
I thought about this
question as well.
And I actually
posed it to Al Roth.
You guys know Al Roth.
He's an economist at Stanford.
He won the Nobel Prize
a couple years ago.
And he thinks a lot
about middlemen.
Anyway, he says no, that really
there's nothing you can say
that is like that because
there's just no limit.
We don't know what
artificial intelligence
is going to be able to do.
I actually talk a little
bit about this in this book.
I mean, in the same
way that we turn
to Netflix with its
sophisticated collaborative
filtering system to recommend
movies that we're really
going to love, there is
no reason, in theory,
in my mind, why we
can't someday turn
to a sophisticated
piece of software that
will ask us natural language
questions to find out
about our tastes and ask
us to rate past experiences
and on the basis
of that construct
the perfect itinerary for us.
That seems like an
impossible challenge,
but, in theory, I don't
see why it's not possible.
I'll say one other
thing about technology.
You know, part of the reason
that people were saying
that middlemen we're
going to go away
is that the internet would
reduce transaction costs.
The cost of finding
what you need,
and finding out about
quality and so on.
And it actually has done that.
It's reduced transaction costs.
And that's why we're able to
book our own travel so often.
If you're just flying
to LA or New York,
staying at a hotel
you've stayed at before,
your transaction costs
for doing that on your own
is really quite low.
And so it makes no sense to turn
to a travel agent to do that.
But the thing about
transaction cost
is that the internet has
lowered transaction costs
for everybody,
including middlemen.
And so middlemen bring whatever
human capital they have.
Whatever skills and
knowledge they have,
they bring it to the task.
And then for them, the
technology is a complement.
So their transaction
costs have actually
fallen faster than our
transaction costs have
for the kind of special,
complex transactions
that we can't easily
do ourselves even
with the aid of technology.
MALE SPEAKER: Though
that they can't never
go to zero marginal
cost for transaction.
MARINA KRAKOVSKY: Yeah.
I mean, yes.
Yes.
There's always
going to be-- yep.
No free lunch, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Let's thank
Marina for her visit to Google.
[APPLAUSE]